prendre un petit café où un apéro pour
les 500 habitants de présence y est en
sancerre ce geste simple du quotidien
est à nouveau possible sans devoir faire
des kilomètres hier un cadre quand même
qui est très sympathique qui donne envie
de venir et puis bah voilà pouvoir
prendre un paquet de tabac boire un
verre s'installer avec des amis et le
temps de discuter un petit peu de se
poser un peu le soir après le travail
c'est toujours agréable quad et d'autres
commerçants aussi nous sur la commune et
pour les conserver je pense que c'est un
tout une boulangerie une boucherie est
désormais un bar tabac restaurant ouvert
sept jours sur sept en saison crézancy
qui a compté jusqu'à 5 a fait autrefois
avait perdu le dernier il ya deux ans
pour enrayer ce déclin la municipalité
rachète le fonds de commerce et rénove
le bâtiment
coût de l'opération 160000 euros on va
enfin avoir un village qui ne va plus
être un désert à certaines périodes de
l'année comme la en période de vacances
il va y avoir les vendanges je pense que
les équipes de vendangeurs vont pouvoir
venir le soir boire un pot ici échanger
sur leur journée de travail
enfin il va y avoir tout un tas de
choses qui vont se passer autour de ce
barça c'est certain il va y avoir une
vie qui va reprendre
et cette vie c'est yannick qui en sera
le chef d'orchestre
ce cuisinier autodidacte a saisi
l'occasion son dossier sélectionné il
investit 30000 euros pour lancer cette
affaire en contrepartie ils reversent à
la commune un loyer à prix d'ami j'ai
pas investi énormément chelem de métier
donc la banque a moins été frileuse de
me prêter de l'argent pour pouvoir
commercer des pour l'épauler yannick a
également embauché un cuisinier et une
serveuse à mi temps